The game of Jeopardy
has three rounds.
Jeopardy, Double Jeopardy, where
the dollar values are doubled,
and Final Jeopardy,
when contestants
can wager an amount of money
on one single question.
Each round has five
questions in six categories.
It consists of a wide
variety of topics,
over 2,500 different categories.
Each question has dollar value.
The first to buzz in and answer
correctly wins the money.
If they answer incorrectly,
they lose the money.
An example of a round involves
the following categories:
Dinosaurs, Notable Women,
Oxford English Dictionary,
Name That Instrument, Belgium,
and Composers by Country.
The type of questions
Jeopardy includes,
includes cryptic definitions
of categories and clues.
And the answer is in
the form of a question.
Let me give you two examples.
Question is: Mozart's last and
perhaps most powerful symphony
shares its name
with this planet.
The answer should be,
"What is Jupiter?"
Another example: smaller
than only Greenland,
it's the world's
second largest island.
And the answer,
"What is New Guinea?"
Welcome back.
Ken, you've got your
signalling device ready I see.
Here are the categories
for you to select
from in Double Jeopardy.
First off, Etude, Brute.
Next, Hedgehog-Podge.
Don't Worry About It.
The Art of the Steal.
Cambridge.
And finally, "Church" & "State"
with each of those words
in quotation marks.
Start us off.
Let's try "Don't
Worry About It",
all the down at $2,000, Alex.
It's just acne!
You don't have this skin
infection also known
as Hansen's disease.
Watson.
What is leprosy?
You are right.
"Etude, Brute" for $1,600.
Music fans wax rhapsodic
about this Hungarian's
"transcendental etudes."
Watson.
Who is Franz Liszt?
You are right.
"Don't Worry About
It" for $1,600.
You're just a little stiff!
You don't have this painful
mosquito-borne joint illness
with a Swahili name.
Watson.
What is Dengue Fever.
Dengue Fever, correct.
"Etude, Brute" for $1,200.
Paganini's "24 Capricci"
set the standard for etudes
for this instrument.
Watson.
What is violin?
Good.